MILE RUN IN THE BEGINNING.
CERTAINLY BRING IT TO YOU ALL
MORNING.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY DEBATE HOW TO SAFELY GET
KIDS BACK IN THE CLASSROOM THIS
FALL.
ARKANSAS IS GIVING THEM THE
GREEN RIGHT TO RETURN TO IN
PERSON LEARNING LATER THIS
MONTH.
TODD: ARKANSAS GOVERNOR ASA
HUTCHISON JOINS US NOW TO
DISCUSS.
GOVERNOR, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
HOW DID YOU MAKE THIS CALL FOR
FIVE DAY A WEEK IN PERSON
SCHOOL?
>> WELL, THE SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT
IS SO IMPORTANT FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
YOU CAN’T HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
EDUCATION.
YOU CAN’T HAVE THE SAME
CONSISTENCY WITHOUT THE INN.
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION.
SHE T. IS VERY CHALLENGING
BECAUSE TEACHERS WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT’S SAFE AS THEY GO BACK.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
STUDENTS TAKE THE PRECAUTIONS
WEAR MASKS AND DO SOCIAL
DISTANCING WHICH THEY’RE NOT
ACCUSTOMED.
TO SAY WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK IN
ARKANSAS AND COUPLE WEEKS LEFT
UNTIL WE ACTUALLY START OUR IN
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO THAT.
THAT’S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US.
WE KNOW IT’S GOING TO BE
CHALLENGING, BUT IT JUST MAKES
ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD
FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE AND THAT
INCLUDES THE SPORTS SIDE OF
THINGS THAT IS IMPORTANT PART
TOO.
IT’S NOT LIKE THEY ARE EITHER
GOING TO BE IN SPORTS OR GOING
TO BE IN THEIR BEDROOM.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE SOMEWHERE
IN THE COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A MORE STRUCTURED
ENVIRONMENT.
AND WE EIGHT TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT AS WELL IN A
SAFE WAY.
GRIFF: GOVERNOR, SPEAKING OF
OPENING DOORS, YOU?
ARKANSAS ARE OPENING THE DOOR TO
THE NRA AS NEW YORK TRIES TO
DISSOLVE THEM WITH THAT NEW
LAWSUIT.
WHY SHOULD THEY MOVE TO
ARKANSAS?
>> WELL, THIS IS A VERY
STARTLING ATTACK AND A
COORDINATED ATTACK FROM THE LEFT
ON AN ORGANIZATION THAT DEFENDS
THE ASSESSMENT.
HAVE YOU GOT BOTH THE LAWSUIT IN
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA AGAINST
THE FOUNDATION.
HAVE YOU GOT THE ATTACK IN NEW
YORK BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AGAINST THE NRA.
IT DOESN’T TAKE ANYONE THAT IS
TOO ASTUTE TO OBSERVE THAT THEY
ARE SIMPLY TRYING TO DESTROY AN
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
AND WHETHER YOU ARE A FIREARM
MANUFACTURER, AN AMMUNITION
MANUFACTURER OR YOU ARE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
IF YOU ARE IN A STATE THAT
DOESN’T APPRECIATE THAT AND
VALUE THAT COME SOUTH.
COME TO ARKANSAS, WE VALUE THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE NRA IS NOT
PERFECT AND IF THERE IS
ACCOUNTABLE ISSUES THERE OUGHT
TO PURSUE THOSE BUT DON’T
DESTROY AN ORGANIZATION BECAUSE
IT SUPPORTS THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
EMILY: THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL
ALLEGATION GOES BACK AT LEAST
THREE YEARS AND CERTAINLY THIS
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN ONGOING
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
REVELATION GET US ELECTION YEAR
DAYS BEFORE HAND.
SEEKING COMPLETE DISSOLUTION
WHEN ALLEGATIONS ARE FOR
CORPORATE FRAUD AND THE PART OF
REDIRECTING FINANCE.
PART OF INCREDIBLE REMEDY THEY
ARE SEEKING AND INCREDIBLE
SOLUTION TO SOMETHING WE USUALLY
ACTUALLY DON’T SEE IN LAW.
>> SO FOREIGN POOR THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND THAT.
AN ACTION THAT SAYS WE WANT TO
MAKE